[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual and amazing
relationships Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions about your life and
your money it is a free call and some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it the phone number is
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Britney is
starting off this hour in Green Bay
Wisconsin hi Brittany welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you for having me sure
what's up
I am calling and originally inquiring
because my husband and I are about nine
hundred thousand dollars in debt we're
both 29 years old
um and we have a large logging business
which consumes the majority of our debt
um we're just trying to figure out what
we can do to minimize this if not get
rid of it completely and get on track to
not continually adding debt but getting
rid of it yeah
so what is um
give me a little breakdown on this
apparently you've got a bunch of heavy
equipment in the logging world right yes
absolutely so we have two pieces of
equipment right now one is valued at
around eight hundred thousand dollars
and the other is valued around five
hundred thousand dollars so those two
big pieces and what is what is owed on
those
so we have the smaller machine paid off
so that there's nothing on that that's
full equity and then we owe around 640
on the larger piece of equipment right
now gotcha okay and
um so that's 640 out of 900.
correct yep and so what is the other 250
so we have our
running vehicles
personal personal yes
yes okay um that will be changing I'm
not sure yeah yeah it's definitely going
to be changing so what what's next
um we have only well around seven
thousand dollars in credit cards right
now so
um what else then we have 90 000 in a
mortgage
um
okay so there's no other business down
no that's still you're still 200 000
short or a hundred thousand dollars
short where's the rest of it
SBA loan when covet hit
so that's the remainder what a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand
two hundred thousand okay all right
what's the net profit of your logging
business in a year
taxable taxable income taxable income
yep around 300. okay good news all right
okay and um
you said you're going to be doing
something to clear these vehicles which
is good because they're out of control
um
and so really you have the the bulk of
this by far is one piece of equipment
correct sir yep okay so there's two two
ways to attack this number one it's a
little bit complicated but uh just
follow me through here what we teach
folks in entree leadership when they
have a business that has debt is you
need to bring home the minimum you can
operate your house with
let's just call that a hundred for
discussion purposes
okay
okay and you bring 100 home you clear
off a bunch of these vehicles you use
the 100 to get rid of the credit card
debt and the the mortgage you're just
going to pay your mortgage until we get
to baby step seven right but we're going
to clear these vehicles by selling them
and or reducing them with your hundred
that leaves us 200
000 to address 800
000 worth of debt at the business
okay
and so if you say I'm going to put uh
of that 200
I'm going to put one 75 towards debt
every year and 25 in retained earnings
every year
I'm gonna put 25 000 in retained
earnings to buy new equipment and to fix
the old equipment and for emergencies
and that kind of thing and then I'm
clearing this SBA loan and I'm clearing
this piece of equipment and of course
the other thing you could consider is
that this piece of equipment was a
mistake
then it needs to be sold to pay off the
debt that was my question is it a nest a
completely necessary piece of equipment
or is it something that you can do
without
so it is a necessary piece of equipment
in order to maintain the the business
now could we get a less expensive option
absolutely that would be you know used
no warranty all of those things on that
yeah um but it is an option to get a
cheaper machine I mean you want to ask
yourself here's the thing you want to
look at when you're buying things for
business
anything you buy for business is an
investment
okay and Investments aren't toys
so an investment for business is what is
the minimum thing the minimum purchase
that will do the job
do the job requires that it has that it
is uh especially we're dealing with
Fleet and you're dealing with equipment
do the job means it has to start it has
to operate can't break down all the time
right so it can't be a piece of crap
that's not doing the job but the other
thing is we don't have to have the
fanciest one with the GPS on it and the
microwave oven in the cab
yeah absolutely if you were to sell this
piece of equipment and get a used piece
what's the price difference there
probably around two hundred thousand
the purchase a used one
oh no that would be the difference okay
so you buy are you interested in a four
instead of 650 you'd pay for you know
450 in debt yeah yeah absolutely yeah
yeah well here's the thing if I'm
looking at this what I'm going to do to
answer your question is we teach people
take your net profit after you've taken
a living wage out and put a percentage
of all your net dollars towards growing
retained earnings and everything else on
the debt and no more purchases with debt
until we have this debt cleared
right and then we pay cash for all
future purchases so you got to make this
piece of equipment last if you're going
to sweat to pay it off because it's
going to take you like four years to
clear this
yes yes absolutely but it's doable I
mean it's doable that doesn't mean it
was a smart thing it doesn't mean it's
what I would do it's not that means the
way I would go at it if you had it to do
over I would have purchased the 200 000
or cheaper one
and I would have saved up and paid cash
for it because that's how I do stuff
here I mean I've got tens of millions of
dollars of hard Assets in this building
um and this one room has about five
miles of wire running through it right
where we do studio in right and so we've
got cameras sitting here they cost a
bazillion dollars we've got everything
else all this stuff we have sitting
around here but you know it's it's we
don't buy the we buy what we call uh MF
minimal functional minimum functional
what what how can it function at a
minimum and because you know the thing
is you gotta if it's Electronics yeah
and if it for that matter if it's a
piece of equipment it's got a shelf life
before it's just not worth anything
that's right yeah you imagine if we're
still trying to operate with non-hd
cameras in this HD world yeah I'd be
that's that just tells me I'm old right
I mean I used to be on the air with
non-hd cameras you know so uh
before HD
well I was on Fox Business when it was
HD and fox wasn't wow yeah when they
first came out it was uh so there's a
day you know but all of a sudden those
cameras poof instantaneously worth zero
just like that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
like this show we would appreciate some
help we don't spend 300 million dollars
on marketing and don't have our own
football stadium like subway uh but
excuse me allergies are bad this time
here but the uh um yeah you know we just
um we just help people
millions of people and so thank you if
you spread the word you can do that by
clicking share on your YouTube or
podcast and share it with share the link
with a friend you can share where you
listen to the show on a talk radio
station near you or watching it on TBN
you can leave us a five star review one
Stars aren't helpful move on if you
don't like it and um
of course you can um subscribe click the
follow the Subscribe button on the uh
YouTube or on podcast wherever you're
listening any of those things help the
old internet algorithm do its thing and
push the show out to the front in front
of people and uh we're able to help more
people because you did those three
things subscribe share and five stars
that's the three things do them right
now Ready set go all right now Sheena Is
With Us sheena's in Salt Lake City Utah
hi Sheena how are you
hi Dave good thank you sure what's up
um so my question is my husband and I
have two rental properties the first one
has 50 of its value mortgaged and we
rent it on Airbnb and made pretty good
money for the last three years the
second one we built with cash on our
shop
and right now we're paying three
thousand dollars on our personal house
monthly to pay it off within the next
five years
my husband would like to get a third
rental in the next three years but we're
bumping heads on how to do this
um I just want to pay off both houses
and then get a third one until in 10
years he wants to pay off our house and
then Finance the third rental is there
an alternative to our ideas to get a
compromise between the two of us
you don't have a um a problem on what to
do you have a problem on
what your beliefs are
correct you have not agreed on your
beliefs and that's more important
than the actual answer to your question
do you guys really need to argue you
need you need to really argue through
because here's the deal
debt 100 of the time
equals risk
more debt equals more risk less debt
equals less risk and no debt equals next
to no risk risk
okay so if you borrow nothing down real
estate crap from some idiot on Tic Tac
and you go buy a whole 10 or 15 houses
with nothing down your payment your
rents aren't even going to cover your
payments because you're fully leveraged
and you're going to lose everything and
go bankrupt because you took so much
debt that you took on the ultimate risk
and it will come home and kick your butt
okay you're not suggesting doing that
but your husband is more in that camp
and you're more in the Dave and Jade
Camp which is we don't borrow money at
all
yeah he always looks for a deal he likes
to get the houses I get a deal too I own
150 million dollars in real estate and I
always get a deal
yeah and I pay cash for it I do it now
pay cash for it I just don't buy it if I
can't pay for it and there's been times
in my life that I've seen stuff come in
front of me that I had to walk away from
because the only way I could get it
would have been to borrow money to buy
it and I'm not going to take the extra
risk I'll wait yeah Sheena I think you
know what we would tell you to do and I
have a feeling that you agree with it
the question is getting your husband on
board with that
that idea right your your husband does
not perceive debt as risk
with houses correct period
and you know and a hundred percent of
the time he's wrong on that do you have
even people that love debt I mean my
friend Robert Kiyosaki believes you
ought to borrow up to your eyeballs on
real estate he loves it he loves that
and he thinks I'm crazy and we're
friends it's okay I like him but he
thinks I'm wrong and I think he's wrong
and so uh but he loves that but even he
will tell you more debt equals more risk
because the margins are tighter the cash
flow is not there and you get bit in the
butt every time there's a little hiccup
in the economy and your renter decides
to go sideways on you whether it's
commercial renter or a residential
renter doesn't matter they go sideways
you can't pay your dadgum payment
because the only way you could do it
would they pay theirs
that's rich
yeah and I like our second one because
it's paid for with cash exactly would
you be interested in selling off the
first one to pay off your personal
mortgage
so the first move into as our retirement
house
it's smaller than our current house and
we're nowhere near retirement yeah how
old are
you uh I'm 39. girl in 70 years we're
going to move into that little house
absolutely we're going to have houses in
the sky I'm not gonna be living in that
house yeah we don't even know what's
going to be here in 70 years that's just
bull crap
so I go back to that first question we
want to move into something like that or
smaller when we get to retirement but
believe me you're not even going to own
that house when you get to return right
right right that's what I would do if
you if it can pull enough money to pay
off your personal mortgage I'd sell off
it now of course you're gonna have to
get the husband on board but I'd sell
off that first one buy you know pay off
your personal mortgage and how quickly
could you then save up to buy another
house in cash
here's the thing I you've just got to
make the debt decision you and your
husband
and you're uncomfortable with it and
he's comfortable with it and you're
uncomfortable with the fact that he's
not being wise enough to actually say
out loud this equals extra risk I can
handle the risk but it does equal extra
risk if he would at least say that out
loud we would all be better off with him
even though he's going to go a different
direction but right now it just sounds
like he acts like that risk isn't there
and it's just there it's there it's 100
there just I mean and people who say let
me tell you here here's how you Jade
here's how you know a person who has not
been a landlord for very long or just
wants to be a landlord
100 percent they are an inexperienced
landlord the renters will pay my
payments
this is someone who has not managed much
rental property the famous last words
yeah that's just absolute horse crap
because the renters are going to do what
the renters are going to do period
passive income and uh yeah it's passive
I got your passive try collecting rent
there ain't nothing passive about it so
uh that's just ridiculous yes no it's
not that that's an inexperienced
landlord so that's true guys here's the
deal the borrower the rituals over the
poor and the borrower is slave
to the lender
he who is impulsive
exalts folly
Folly is an old word but it basically is
a fool in action
a fool while moving is folly you get to
watch the a person's Folly you're
watching a fool make make his life
horrible right he who is impulsive
is a fool in action
the rituals over the poor the borrower
is slave
to the lender now what does slavery mean
well it does not mean literal slavery
well whatever controls you you're a
slave to yeah there you go but I mean
it's not it's not literal it's not like
the sex slave trade or something like
that right but but uh but it is a thing
where you don't you have to keep working
that job because you got to pay that
bill yep you got to collect that rent
and you have to be mean to somebody you
didn't want to be mean to yeah because
you got to pay that bill doesn't matter
if your tenant has stage three breast
cancer and can't work and she's a single
mom you've still got to pay the bill or
she's going to get evicted when they
foreclose on you so you've got to force
her you cannot be generous to her
because you were a slave to freaking
Citibank
that's right and so this is you don't
you don't have the margin to be kind and
strong and courageous when you're a
slave slaves don't think about
generosity slaves think about tomorrow
they don't think about five years from
now slaves think about avoiding pain
and hope the master is nice and no one's
thinking like that Dave I'm just
thinking I get this house the renter
pays every month I got this margin
they're only thinking about the best
possible scenario they're not thinking
about the real world situation that you
just described that I'm sure is
happening every day on
yeah you know 100 so we love real estate
like I said I've got a bunch of it
and I pay cash for it the interesting
thing is it cash flows like a bandit
when you get it paid for and so you can
buy your next one pretty quick with a
rinse off of that one because you don't
need the money oh you got time to get a
good tenant in there you're not and it's
pure rent yeah it's pure money you're
not you're not siphoning all three
quarters of your wrench and going back
to some stupid mortgage company so you
can save up and pay cash for the next
one pretty quick this is the Ramsey
Center
[Music]
yeah
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back there why
their wash and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Ty is my co-host today thank you for
joining us America we're so glad you're
here hey if you listen to the show long
enough you can piece together what we
teach and you can make some progress
with your money you can jump around and
try to get all the puzzle pieces and
maybe you can fit some of them together
on YouTube most of our stuff is there
um and all over the place for that
matter on the internet oh and by the way
before it was our stuff it was called
common sense so it's all been around but
right now what we have figured out is
that it's hard to get to the level you
should
as fast and easy as you should without
the proven system in detail brick upon
brick upon brick upon brick and people
walking with you
now imagine if the person that was
walking with you was like Jade warshaw
but Ramsay personality like Rachel Cruz
or Dr John deloney or Ken Coleman or
Eddie Cullen or wow even George Campbell
yep I mean there you go these people
walking beside you they're actually
going to be Financial Peace University
coordinators
yep online you can join a virtual class
and they are going to coordinate the
group and the others be there once a
week to have a discussion with you hold
you accountable get things going and you
just did one of these this is your
second one it's my second one we started
last night Dave
um and just for anybody listening you
literally have until tomorrow to sign up
for my class you can still sign up we'll
send you the video for the one you
missed and then get started in person on
lesson two and I'm telling you man we
had a blast last night we had a good
time yeah well the the first class is
you're nice well and then later on you
you get means
it is I actually had to tell it like it
was a couple of times last night even
already
a little bit because you know the girl
wanted to go to birthday parties instead
of payoff debt and stuff like that so I
had to tell her
the girl the girl there's always one
Chantelle she knows who she is listening
and so is your whole group yeah that's
right we have a good time well we have
accountability because we love you and
uh and we have encouragement if you're
struggling and you're scared uh all of
that goes with the deal so all the
meanness Society it's not really mean
it's just us telling you the truth and
in a world where everyone lies and
doesn't tell the truth telling the truth
sounds really harsh
it sounds hurtful but it's actually the
best medicine that's right so hey George
or Rachel or Jade or John or Ken or
Eddie would love to work with you and be
your coordinator and all the
personalities are leading Financial
Peace University Rachel and Jade started
yesterday but you can still get in to
sign up for a class go to fpu.com
fpu.com or go to ramsaysolutions.com and
just find the FPU and you'll find the
personality page take FPU with a
personality it's a fun idea we've never
done this before in all the years of
doing this Financial Peace University
and it's quite popular very very big
deal Brandon is with us in Huntsville hi
Brandon how are you
I'm good how about you Dave better than
I deserve what's up
okay I wanted to get your advice on my
retirement investing
so my employer offers a rough 401K great
if I put in seven percent then they will
match five percent correct so my
question is should I put in seven
percent into my raw 401 and put eight
percent into a Roth IRA or should I just
put all of my uh 15 into the Roth 401.
I'd put 15 into the Roth 401 because it
is a Roth version and there's the match
there and then if for some reason uh
your 15 maxes out your Roth 401k then
you can move over to a Roth IRA yeah
it's amazing that they offer that
benefit that's a great benefit great
that's a great deal now two things one
is that's assuming that the uh mutual
funds in your 401k are good ones okay
you got good track record mutual funds
in there if you do then Jade's exactly
right now if your 401k is weak I'd still
take the match because 100 ready to
return before we start helps even week
one go okay so um or not 100 but close
five five on seven right so
um and then you would go over to Roth
and get really good juicy mutual funds
if yours aren't juicy there so but I
suspect yours are probably fine and so
I'd probably do just exactly what Jade
said if you're comfortable with the
quality of the mutual funds in the 401K
now you know the match portion is not
Roth It's not allowed to be
okay the match portion will be
traditional now at the uh our once
you're in baby step seven you can roll
your traditional match per per portion
into a Roth but you'll have to pay the
taxes on that amount of money when you
do that I would not do that until you're
in baby step seven
I do that every year I'm on the company
so oddly enough I match myself how
whacked is that and um then I roll it
over into a Roth and pay the taxes on
the match portion every year because the
companies are required to match with
traditional 401K dollars so but you got
a sweet deal but it sure does that's a
great deal it's a good match and the
fact that they've got the Roth that
tells me their mutual funds are probably
high quality so you're probably just
fine Austin is with us in Chicago hey
Austin Town
hey Dave how's it going good man what's
up
well I've been um struggling for a year
here since I made the um New college
graduate stupid decision and bought a
car
you're right that's stereotypical man
let's love it what'd you buy man
a 2018 Jeep Compass
wow
yeah time
all right
how much did you owe on how much do you
owe on this piece of crap
000. no
yeah yep it's been hurting and um what
do you make
about 63 Grand right now should be
bumping up to 75 come January 1st good
good okay and that's working 40 hours
yes yep how can we help you sir
I just want to know because I've been
teeter-tottering on this because
I owe 21 the trade-in value is like 10-5
wherever I go give or take a thousand
yeah and like
I'm like okay I want this thing out of
my life create a car with negative
equity in on this thing
no no I went from a 2005 Toyota Corolla
zero uh to 100 with this 2018 Jeep
Compass so you how in the world do you
lose ten thousand dollars in value in
one year car sucks Dave I know it sucks
and I think they overcharged him for a
sucky card
everybody I talked to said that they
were stunned by the sticker price what I
paid for it and then on top of that and
you said you're how old
I'm 25. oh that's awesome hey this is
great news because you have the whole
rest of your life to never make that
mistake again that's true oh Lord I
won't because you by God have thoroughly
learned this lesson I'm so sorry
what a horrible thing to go through so
you're ten thousand dollars upside down
you owe 21 what other debt have you got
I got a
uh 85 000 in student loan
and uh seven in credit cards okay
all right
um
well you're stuck so here's what you're
gonna do you're going to work like a
maniac you need two more jobs
I've been thinking about that too yeah I
want you you know you're not going to
see the inside of a restaurant vacation
and certainly not bar hopping on the
weekends and Shot Town definitely got a
few of those so we're gonna uh we're
gonna work all the time and because
here's let's just pretend that you made
90 and you're single and you don't you
can't spend any money because all you do
is work right you'd have a big old pile
of money out of 90 to knock out what
amounts to about a hundred thousand
dollars worth of debt
what's your living situation
uh right now um my fiance and I are
actually renting
okay when you're getting married
uh not till 2025. why
uh give us some time to clean up this
mess and uh as a married couple that
people do it all time
it's fair enough does she have death
I don't know exactly the mess is is that
if you guys work together as a married
couple you're gonna do this a whole lot
faster a whole lot more efficiently
[Music]
um and so that's what I would recommend
I wouldn't recommend waiting until
everything's perfect to get married
because you've already decided to get
married and figure it out neither one of
you is perfect so
um yeah hang on I'm going to give you a
Financial Peace University I want you to
go through that and I really do I want
you to Gear Up get about six jobs I want
you to tear into the step like your life
depends on it because dude it does
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thanks
for being with us America open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five bills in Hartford Connecticut hey
Bill how are you hi Dave and Kate thank
you very much for taking my call sure
what's up um
so I have a question
um so I own a condo with my wife and um
I was wondering is it possible to rent
instead of owning a condo to save up to
buy a house
why what is your opinion why
oh I owned uh so I live in an apartment
condo and house and me personally I like
the house better I like the house is the
best
okay but I mean you want to buy a house
I got that but why don't you just uh
does a condo have equity
um
I don't I mean uh well here's the thing
um I bought it for 160 000 and it could
probably sell now for 185 000 because um
that's what my neighbor sold his for
okay so you're not gotten much Equity by
the time you by the time you pay
expenses you're just going to get out
you think so yeah yeah yeah
twenty thousand dollars you're gonna
spend
you're probably going to spend most of
that on commissions and expenses to sell
the property I mean not maybe not quite
that much but yeah very well could so um
yeah you're not going to come out with a
big pile of money or anything when you
sell it
um and then you're gonna go rent
something and save up a down payment
well what do you think what you said
is that what you said
yep yeah what are you paying now every
month
um so the mortgage um this is including
the condo fees is 12.32 a month do you
think that you would be able to rent for
cheaper than that
well um I looked online and the rent
ranges from 1200 to 1500 to 1300 in
Connecticut yeah yeah so a one or two
bedroom
so you're not going to do any better
okay so here's the situation
so stuff like say for example the
furnace went out I had to pay you know
four thousand dollars to replace it yeah
because you own it
yep
um I mean would it uh benefit me to live
in a place where I don't have to pay for
um to fix things up I wouldn't do it I
would stay where you're at if it was
some drastic you know if you had a bunch
of equity in there that you could get
your hands on that would be one thing if
you found that it was going to be a
drastic change you know between renting
and what you're paying now in ownership
I you know you could consider it but for
you there's no real difference I mean
you got to put your emergency fund aside
you know for things that pop up and yes
home ownership or condo ownership in
your case does come with things that you
know you're on the hook to repair but in
your case I think there's no reason that
you can't start saving for a home now
how much do you earn every month
um 5300 after taxes yeah okay so here's
the thing
three years from today
between now and three years if that's
what it took or four years or five years
if that's what it took to buy the next
house to save up to us by the next house
during that three four or five year
period of time rent is going to go up
every year
okay and the value of your condo is
going to go up every year
but your payment is not
so I would stay in the condo and keep my
expenses low even though you just had
this horrible thing of having to buy a
furnace and that's kind of made you go
kilter on it sideways but Jade's exactly
right I would sit right there until I
can save up my down payment and or the
condo grows more in value and will help
provide you with a down payment for the
next move yeah I don't disagree with you
that a home is a better standard of
living for most folks especially in the
early stages of your life moving towards
marriage kids that kind of stuff so I
think you're I think your direction is a
good direction but what I would do is
sit tight and let's have this fixed low
payment and deal with whatever repairs
but also get the benefit of increased
value and while you're trying to save up
and buy something that's exactly it and
I want to make sure that if he has debt
he pays that off first absolutely clear
your debts and and be working on your
income during that time too which will
affect what you can buy Dave is in
Philadelphia hi Dave welcome the Ramsey
Show
all right thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um so my I'm expecting my income to
increase pretty dramatically in two
years but in the meantime I'm having
trouble paying costs including two kids
in daycare so my question is is it okay
to go into debt take out a loan or is it
better to become extremely preferable
and cut costs as much as possible
uh C work more
none of the above
so what what is this guaranteed income
increase this dramatic in two years
explain to me what's going on
my wife is doing a medical residency so
in two years she'll be done with that
and get a job as a doctor yeah I will
increase things pretty dramatically
that's great and how much debt will you
guys have
um right now we have
um we own a house and aside from the
house we have about twenty five thousand
dollars in student loan debt and is she
borrowing to finish medical school
no she has no med school debt wow the
student bed is mine okay so that she'll
graduate debt free in two years
The Residency right now but I mean
she'll finish she'll finish and pass her
boards after residency and become an MD
that's correct okay excellent and no
more so what's she making in residency
about seventy thousand and what are you
making
about a hundred and ten thousand can you
explain to me why you can't get bound
not right
dollars
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars
and you're gonna explain that with child
care costs hold on how much are you
paying a month in child care
uh it's about 80 000 a year
why
you bought them in college
the the base tuition for the child
daycare we use is 25 000 per kid then we
pay extra for early care and Aftercare
and it doesn't go during the summer so
during the summer we need a nanny
uh there's there's cheaper route I know
that there won't be as nice as I can
Dave you guys have lost your minds
there's cheaper routes oh you think
there's cheaper routes that's all I can
say because you got them in some kind of
dad gum I mean are they going to Harvard
what the crap
it is a pretty fancy you don't think you
can downgrade yeah I think
they're not even
even you're already paying 25 000 ahead
come on dude that's just dumber and crap
seriously downgrade it's time to uh it's
time to to take the the kids off filet
mignon I don't care how much money you
make there's not enough money in the
world it doesn't make that stupid gosh
find you a free summer camp anything
during the summer time we're gonna
borrow money now we're going to take out
student loans for the four-year-old
because that's what we're coming down to
don't do it no you make 180 000 yeah I
think you need to become Frugal if
that's what the definition of living on
180 Grand is yeah you're killing me
daycare is exp Day Care can be expensive
but it doesn't have to be that expensive
let's just 25 000 a kid yeah I think not
unbelievable I think not I think not no
uh
yeah I think I think you can just I'm
having trouble here I think he can get I
think he can get it for half that half
that yeah yeah in Pennsylvania I gotta
believe that yeah yeah
if not we're open to the daycare
tomorrow I know right Dave's daycare
Philly Dave's kids heading off to Philly
they'll load up the truck and head to
Beverly oh my gosh
there's golden nose daycare Hills
this is like George's Doggy Daycare
people man the things we now call
Necessities in this culture so no sweet
guy you're a nice man I'm sorry to make
fun of you but that's crazy and you all
need to cut that out that's not a good
investment your children are precious
and yes they're worth whatever but you
don't need to be nuts about it yeah and
and this is crazy especially when you
tell me you're talking about borrowing
money to cover this expense among others
because you got what two kids or three
kids at 25k a piece
2 is 50k for daycare for two kids that's
too much I think we can universally
agree among all the listener base yeah
nope
then then guess what you've solved your
problem you don't have to borrow money
David seriously if you say out loud in
America today I can't make it on 180 000
so I need to borrow money just the fact
that you enunciated that is a problem
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Greg is in Sacramento hey
Greg welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave uh thank you sure
my adult son
terstone which is heart stopped and he
had little to no blood flow for
15 to 30 minutes or so yeah and as a
result he suffered a brain injury and
um was in the hospital for uh six months
wow and they
but the amazing thing is he survived and
he's actually doing remarkably well uh
even though they didn't expect him to
survive
um he's still in recovery but he's
hoping to be able to work and live on
his own again and hopefully within a
year or so but he did incur a lot of
medical debt uh given that he's not
working yet and he he had some debt
before that yeah um fortunately the
hospital itself forgave 2.5 million
dollars for which we're extremely
grateful so he had no insurance
uh no that was with insurance
I mean the insurance covered
uh whatever they covered and then the
the
Hospital said the total bill was 2.5
million yeah
yeah but and then they forgave them they
forgave the rest that's very nice okay
right yeah we're grateful for that but
he does still have about 45k in medical
debt and that's to about 30 different
providers
um additionally he had I think about
15km personal left prior to that most of
that's all in collections right now and
I'm just trying to
I'd like to know how I can best help him
deal with the debt
um so how's he doing with the brain
injury what is what what is he back is
he 70 back 89 back how how's he doing
well it's hard to tell in some areas
he's probably 100 but in other areas
he's got difficulties
um he's he's taking a course at a junior
college right now and it's he's actually
doing really well in the course but it's
hard for it's uh take some he says it
takes me a lot longer and it's very
draining physically on him but how it is
but anyway he's doing well he's actually
39. wow how old are you
so she's starting over kind of now I'm
67. okay what is your wealth transition
look like
um we're in pretty good shape we've got
uh we've got some
did you ask about my positions yes sir
what's your name what's your net worth
oh uh if I count the house probably two
200 250 and then 401K about 250e okay
and so half million a million dollars
okay all right good something like that
and actually we started following you uh
in 2014 because my daughter introduced
this to to your show and uh she actually
used to groom your dog oh wow okay and
that's how she met she met you guys and
then pulled told us you should follow
this and so we it changed it changed
things for us okay so can you help him
financially
um well we have been in that he's living
with us and we did cover everything uh
everything for him and all of this uh
like medical copays and things up until
he just started getting SSDI a little
bit ago and now he's paying for for most
of that
um
um okay so how can we help you
well I'd like to know how best to deal
with uh his debt that's gone into
collections he has a he has some money
saved up from since he's been getting
SSDI he's hoping to get out of us on
um about 15 000. okay you can settle 45
for 15. on bad medical debt
so now I if if he has the emotional
strength if he doesn't then you help him
with that yeah he really doesn't okay he
can sign over the rights for you to
discuss this account
and here's how this goes you call the
collector that a thousand dollars is
owed to and you say we do he does not
have but 25 percent of what is owed so
we are offering you 25 of what is owed
and if you do not take that you're going
to get nothing
so it's up to you do you want to do this
or not wait wait wait wait wait wait no
we're gonna give you 25 cents on the
dollar or you're going to get nothing
what do you want to do no
we're going to give you you're going to
have to repeat it because these people
are dumb okay over you're going to just
stand there and just over and over and
over and over if they want to get nasty
say no we're not going to have nasty
conversations you're going to get to
talk to a dial tone I'm going to push
that little end button on my phone if
you just get nasty but we're going to do
25 cents on the dollar and if you don't
want to do that I'll call you next month
and see if you've changed your mind and
until you want to do that you're not
getting anything oh and by the way
you're not having an electronic two
things under no circumstances do you
give them money until you have the
agreed amount in writing right
and under no circumstances do they have
electronic access to accounts
so they cannot have give me your
checking account number we'll just draft
it absolutely not they will clean him
out they lie
yeah you're gonna have to call a couple
of times to get this locked in yeah you
can tell a collector is lying if their
mouth is moving
yeah I'm I'm usually not the person that
the yeah you're not going to be you're
not going to be comfortable finding out
that this level of humanity exists in
our culture
is the underbelly of what's going on out
there but you just got to be really
tough and really firm you can have a
little fun with it and be sarcastic and
mean back if you want or you can just be
really tough and really firm and go look
we're through talking now I'll call you
next month okay you're gone next hey we
have 25 cents on the dollar you want to
take that give it to me in writing I
will give you I I will send it to you uh
certified mail return receipt requested
cashiers checked uh or we'll get a
prepaid debit card for that amount
whatever we can find some way where they
can't access his account and clean out
the 15K or clean out 100 cents on the
dollar after they agreed to 25 cents on
the dollar and you got how many of these
creditors you got to deal with Greg
about 30. yeah it's going to be fun not
I know not and I heard that once you do
then they all start hounding you again
pounding my son again right no no no no
no no no once it's once it's settled in
full and you have it in writing he's
done just keep that forever though keep
it enough you're settling this on his
behalf he's giving you he's going to
give you a sheet that says in writing
that you have permission to settle this
account for him because he's meant he's
disabled he's got a brain injury right
and so you could get nothing people but
we're trying to give you what he does
have
so you're being honorable because all
you're going to give them everything
he's got
you're being honorable and settling it
so
um you know and just keep just keep
talking to them and talking to them but
you're dealing with people that couldn't
get a job shoveling out of septic tank
and so they're sitting on the phone
being a collector instead this that's
honorable by the way
that's not this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you foreign
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services with 19 service Brands
Nationwide neighborly's network of
providers have trusted local service
professionals to handle more than a
thousand different services in and
around your home go to neighborly.com
and find a schedule and service today
all right today's question comes from
Jim in Arizona he says we pay extra on
our mortgage each month so that we can
get rid of it more quickly very good
we're wondering if refinancing while
still paying extra will put more towards
the principal and help us pay it off
faster even though the interest rate
would be slightly higher so here's the
details our current mortgage is a
15-year at 2.75 percent the balance is a
hundred and three thousand our current
monthly payment is 1700 a month and we
are paying 2500 a month very good right
now we would pay it off in four years
and the house is worth over 600k if we
refinance our monthly payment would be
760 dollars a month and from what I've
read the interest does not apply to the
overage amount paid and is directly
applied to the principal interest-free
is this true
Dave have you ever read something and it
makes so little sense that it makes you
question your own
yeah level of intelligence everything on
the internet is not true Abraham Lincoln
said that so yeah there you go yeah no I
wouldn't refinance number one you have
2.75 why would you go up to a six plus
you know person interest rate for this
you've got because he thinks that the
interest was all charged on the front
end and he's not and that he's he
doesn't understand how this really works
that's why yeah okay so here's how it
really works
the interest is calculated on a mortgage
just like a simple interest loan now how
does that what does that mean means you
take your annual interest rate in this
case
2.75 you divide that by 12. when you do
that you're going to get 0.22 so about a
quarter of a percent per month okay and
so whatever balance is outstanding
that month
one quarter of one percent or 0.22
percent is going to be multiplied by
that and that is the interest that is
owed that month
now let's say that's a hundred thousand
dollars okay and so if you paid that
that tiny little bit of interest and you
paid five thousand dollars more towards
your mortgage the next month
the amount of Interest would be 95 000
times
0.223 okay
and if you pay down one thousand dollars
the next month it's going to be the
interest is
ninety four thousand dollars times point
two two three and so the only way a
mortgage gets paid off faster due to a
refinance is if you get a lower interest
rate
not a higher interest rate it's
mathematically impossible for your
mortgage to be paid off faster
with a higher interest rate there is no
scenario in which that works so whatever
you read confused you or was just wrong
and the most of what you read these days
about Finance on the Internet is just
wrong because it's just really basic
math the amount outstanding that month
the balance the principal balance that
month times the monthly
portion of the interest your annual rate
divided by 12. okay that tells you how
much of your payment is going to
interest everything else is going to
reduce principle so let's do some quick
dirty math okay a hundred thousand bucks
at two and three quarters that's twenty
seven hundred and fifty dollars per
hundred thousand yes per year okay okay
if you pay twenty five hundred a month
which is what he's doing now
that's thirty thousand dollars a year
thirty thousand times three is ninety
okay during that time we've had around
three thousand dollars in interest build
up per year so he should be debt free in
three and a half years if he just pays
twenty thirty thousand dollars a year
in three years we would have paid off 90
plus a little interest okay or so our
minus a little interest so call it 85
right all right which will leave him
about 15 more thousand so in about three
and a half years he's debt free with a
two and three quarter percent mortgage
that ain't bad if you just keep doing
what you're doing dude yeah if you add
more to it of course it's going to go
away even faster right and if you add a
lump sum to it today it'll go away the
next month you're not going to pay
interest on anything except what is left
that's how simple interest is calculated
and that's how a mortgage is calculated
uh with any standard mortgage that's out
there now there are some ripoff Finance
Company mortgages that use the rule of
78 which has a prepayment penalty built
into it and you do not get credit for
the interest by prepaying principal on
those but that's if you've got an 18
interest rate and you went to the
storefront like beneficial which is not
um or something like that right you're
going one of these rip-off it's right
next to the pawn shop oh you know
gracious little personal you know you
get a 38 interest rate on a personal
loan of 5 000 bucks in there those kinds
of places right yeah so you can go in
there but and get a different mortgage
but all FHA VA Fannie Mae home equity
loans whether Traditional Bank or credit
union they're all run on simple interest
with no prepayment penalty and so you do
not pre-pay the interest the reason that
your payment is X and most of it goes to
interest and when you have a 30-year
mortgage on your first payment is
because your balance is so stinking High
still and when it's multiplied by your
interest rate divided by 12 right it
takes up most of your monthly payment
that's right that's why it starts out
but if you look towards the end of
paying it off almost all of it is almost
all your payment then if you're just pay
in your regular payment is going towards
principal why because your back balance
is infinitely small at that point you've
got five grand left on your balance and
you're you know you're paying a thousand
dollars a month so of course most of the
Thousand is not going to be interest
because there's not a lot of interest on
five grand that's right well Dave this
is this is why you've got the goat
status I think that was a great job of
explaining that wonderful I mean it's
just it's
yeah and so
Jim thank you for coming to us
because the problem with this kind of
stuff is it causes people to do stupid
butt stuff it does and here's the thing
here's what's scary there's people in
the mortgage business that don't know
what I just said I guarantee it and they
will sell you a six percent mortgage as
a method of getting out of debt when you
have a two and three quarter percent
mortgage well they're also going to get
paid off of that so well there's that
some of them but some of them do it out
of ignorance not not Melody I mean I
just don't know people this is really
basic stuff but you know the other let's
just take it one step further just be
real nerdy okay you and Sam ever get
your amortization schedule yes yes we
got The Columns of the interest in the
principle it's if you go to take your
calculator and do what I just said to do
it's exactly what you're going to find
that's how that's developed that's the
spreadsheet formula that I just gave you
that you plug in the spreadsheet formula
and it creates those M tables those
amortization tables all right because
that shows you the Porsche you know I
got a payment of a thousand this much as
principal the this tiny little bits
principle it's the first the whole big
thing's interest and then it goes to the
bottom and right to the bottom that's
why it's exciting to look at because you
start seeing and show more of your money
go take your am schedule and you say
okay I'm currently oh two hundred
thousand dollars on my am schedule and
you find that place on your M schedule
and you say what would happen if I paid
fifty thousand dollars in principal next
month will you slide down to where you
find a hundred and fifty thousand dollar
balance and you'll see how much of your
payment is going to go to interest and
how much is going to go to principal
yeah because so we're literally doing is
you're sliding forward in the M schedule
by prepaying principal to the next level
or to the next place at that principal
amount equals that that's how it works
and that's but it's all based on the
idea of the interest that is charged
only on the outstanding balance monthly
it's not bi-weekly right once a month so
you could pay four times during the
month doesn't change a thing doesn't
change a thing because they only they
only reset once a month and so at the
end at the beginning of the month
whatever's outstanding
times your monthly interest rate is
going to give you your interest charged
and so that's how this process works
that's a good question it was and a
great explanation and I'm glad Jim that
you uh sent it in here uh we're not
making fun of you for not knowing
because most people don't know this and
a lot of people think that because the
interest is so large on the front end
that they're paying all the interest up
front and you're not
you're only paying the interest that you
owe each month that's all this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
common sense for your dollars and cents
Gwen's with us in Tampa hi Gwen welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
um my issue is my husband and I restored
a 1966 Airstream and um used it
unfortunately he passed away and it's
time to Let It Go
um so my question is my niece and this
question has been expressed and
interested in it a long time ago and
said hey if you're ever interested in
selling it or that's the way they put it
you know let us know so I had written
him a letter my question is we're
supposed to talk tomorrow and I thought
you know I don't know how this is
supposed to go what's what's fair I do
have another niece and another nephew
and we have a trust as well but bottom
line is I thought you know I just want
to be fair I don't know
Slow Down slow down how long ago did
your husband pass
how long ago did your husband pass away
he passed away four years ago I'm so
sorry
and you guys rebuilt this camper
together
oh you had it restored okay so what is
it worth if you were just to sell it on
the open market
I actually
um um it was valued at surprisingly and
shockingly it's a valued at thirty three
thousand dollars why is that shocking is
it shockingly low or high
uh well it is high for me and it's it's
1966 but my um people that we have at
service regularly Carl said oh my gosh
these are really into me it's kind of a
it's kind of a uh it's kind of a cool
it's a family right now yeah it's a fad
that's a cool thing yeah all right so
you have a 33 000 camper
and one of your family members wants to
buy it
four years ago I said hey uh if you're
ever interested in selling it please let
us know okay I'm letting you know it's
thirty three thousand dollars
I'm letting you know I'm getting ready
to put the camper up for sale for thirty
three thousand dollars in two weeks
would you like it before I put it up for
sale
did you already do that Gwen
we're going to talk I asked them if they
were interested I'd like to give them
first crack at it and they said can we
give you a call tomorrow and I said
absolutely let's talk tomorrow and I
thought I I don't know how to I don't
want to spend noon but I also don't want
to be if they're offended by you selling
your camper for what it's worth and
that's their problem
okay do you think they're expecting some
sort of a deal because it's family
is that what you're worried about I
would guess
that I would guess
why
I I don't I'm not very good uh thinking
on my feet I get a little flustered and
I thought well you don't have to think
on your feet yeah you don't think on
your feet you're going to sell your
camper for thirty three thousand dollars
or if you want to give them a deal just
because you as an act of love and you've
got a pile of money and you don't need
any money do you need money
money we're establishing a scholarship
for my husband in his hot in my
husband's name
at the high school and then they're
helping with that if they buy the camper
and you can tell them that
yeah I'm gonna sell the camper and
whatever I get out of it is going to go
into his scholarship fund over at the
school
and so and the guys at the at the camper
place tell me it's worth 33 000. so I'm
gonna put it up for sale for 33 000. if
you want to sell it to them for 30 and
just say that that's fine but you don't
have to think on your feet this is not a
negotiation this is you just putting a
price on something and what it's worth
there's nothing to be flustered about
it's just I
am or is it making you feel some type of
way is that what it is because you feel
like you're it sounds like this is just
ringing you out right now
well I
thought that's an assistant for it to
just sit
um but so it feels like you're selling a
little bit of what was your husband's in
your dream mm-hmm
we loved it yeah it's going to be it's
going to be kind of emotional the day it
leaves
yeah well I I have to tell you it's uh
it's Beyoncé it's beyond me and I mean
and he was loved he would love it to go
to them if Andy that's the thing okay
but I don't think he meant for you to
give it to them for free do you
oh no
I think he was expecting you to give
this camper away for free
I don't either
yeah you're not it's not an act of
you're not being mean when you sell
something to anyone for what it is worth
now if it's worth 33 and you sold it to
them for 43 that's being immoral right
okay but you're when you sell something
for what it's worth you have done
absolutely nothing wrong if you choose
to discount it slightly not as an act of
being pressured or feeling some kind of
guilt trip but just as an act of
generosity then that's your choice it's
your item and you can do that too so you
say you know they the guys at the store
tell us it's worth 33 that's what I'm
gonna put it on the market for but
because my husband would love it if you
guys had it and knew and we knew that
you were using it you know we'll sell it
to you guys for 30. instead of 33. and
the money is going to a scholarship fund
so it's yeah it's still
generosity yeah
does that make sense
but I don't think I don't think we're
going much lower than that
okay and if they have an expectation of
that that's their problem
because no promise was made ever in any
conversation of these people that they
were getting a free camper yeah they
said when it goes for sale let us know
not when you give the camper away let us
know
there it is there it is this is what's
called Nunya
Nunya business
okay I don't know who this family member
is but they're not in this transaction
but I just figured out what you're
worried about and what you're feeling
guilty about and what all your fields
are about that Jade was smelling it's
this family member
who was a member of his family not yours
correct
actually
um
your husband's family member of my
family oh of your family okay then you
can really tell them where to yeah
exactly this is called good boundaries
and I don't think I asked you and I
don't think I will be asking you and
this is Nunya that's what you call it a
Taco Burrito conversation nachos
oh
nachos nachos nachos
I love that I've never heard that that
is fabulous Henry Cloud will love that
the author of boundaries nachos okay
mic drop right there
last time I looked at the title it says
nachos nachos it says mine
that is so good I don't know if I'm
gonna get out of here or not get me to a
commercial Lord oh that's so good that's
the ultimate boundaries joke right there
it is I'm gonna email that to Henry
right now oh man I knew something was
going on in that though you're right
just nailed it and I thought it was a
grieving over her husband at first and
then I'm like there's something with
this it's her mama or somebody that
needs a not needs a nachos and
nachos
you don't get to speak into this that is
so great whoever it is has been sniffing
around that camper for a while now too
yeah they've got their own little they
got their own little game going don't
they or they just like to screw around
in other people's business true which
some folks nachos is so much better than
Nunya
not in your dadgum business because that
works pretty good they're cousins mind
your own mind your own it's a full-time
job this is Nunya Nunya and it's nachos
it's so great
well I'm glad I'm glad I introduced you
to something I bet deloney doesn't know
that oh well we'll hear that on the
mental health show the doctor John
deloney show when he's opening people's
set boundaries this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host thank you for
joining us America we're glad you're
here this is the Ramsey Show uh when you
graduated from high school did uh
anybody give you a copy of a Dr Seuss
book as a gift
uh
hope not
High School oh the Places You'll Go
oh that's the one that's my guess anyway
yeah okay I was thinking what the crap
at first I went to Green Eggs and Ham
for high school
okay but here's the let's just try
something let's do a graduation gift
that actually matters oh the Places
You'll Go Okay the get clear assessment
is built specifically for teenagers they
spend some time answering questions in
just a few minutes they get customized
results about their specific top talents
passions and Mission and that kind is
the kind of guidance that gives them
confidence about the major they choose
the career field they lean towards and
avoid wasting uh years and tens of
thousands of dollars on courses on
degrees they don't need want or hate
people spend years of their lives trying
to figure this stuff out and you can
give them the get clear assessment
for students for 30 bucks at
ramseysolutions.com go to the store
or you can give them Dr Zeus
your choice
so now we're trashing Dr Seuss and our
head coach well you know is that how
Un-American is that the point is it's
better I'd rather have the assessment
though than the book I would too but why
can't we pick on somebody other than Dr
Seuss do both and this I'm like anchor
man I just read whatever's put in front
of me apparently
oh my God this is awful no I'm not gonna
trash Dr Seuss anymore tell these mean
people in marketing to rewrite their
coffee they're just meanies just big old
meanies so seriously all joking aside
get the uh get the get get your kids to
take this assessment wouldn't you have
loved as a high school senior to have a
freaking clue about what you were
leaning into love it would have loved
that ramseysolutions.com store what's
the name of the book where we're telling
them not to buy oh the Places You'll Go
oh I think you ought to get that too not
to be confused when did you just throw
that in with the get clear assessment we
don't have any of those so we can't oh
the Places You'll Go Rodney's in
Washington D.C Rodney how are you
I'm very good thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
um well
um 58 years old
um my brain and I'm retired my bring
home pay is uh 3 800 I have about 36 000
cash in the bank
135 in one retirement account and 230 in
the other retirement account good I owe
43 000 on my house and I what what babe
to buy a new car I'm not 100 needed
right now but I want to so I'm trying to
figure out should I take a little bit of
money out of my retirement account and
buy the car outright or should I just
uh pay the house off first or something
else
how much were you thinking about
spending
actually the car is going to be
approximately forty thousand dollars
yeah so about close to the same amount
that I owe for my mortgage
um well I mean you're certainly allowed
to do that it's not against the law but
you called us and asked us okay yes sir
and your you said you're how old
I'm 58. okay all right
I'm a car guy so I can relate I mean I
like a great car I got my my big Raptor
with loud mufflers and my sports cars
and I love that stuff so I'm with you on
all this but the the problem is is that
these toys are going to cost you parts
of your future that you don't want them
to cost you
so we don't a number one we don't
recommend buying a car a brand new car
unless you have a million dollar net
worth because they go down in value so
fast so we don't do that and you're not
there so we're not buying a new one
anyway so let's talk about a used one in
a used one we don't recommend buying
anything you can't pay cash for and that
the total of all of the items that you
own that has Motors or Wheels does not
equal more than half your annual income
and you said you make what a year
uh again I'm retired my bring home for
my uh pension is about three thousand oh
yeah that's right okay now you're
retired at 58.
yes sir you don't work at all I'm very
lucky
um uh I sell some stuff on eBay but
that's it okay Mom are you married
no sir I'm not okay so what do you what
is it what do you spending your time
doing
so
um besides looking at new cars even
right uh I sell stuff on eBay just uh
nothing much of anything what's the uh
what's the car you're thinking of
um probably like a Hyundai Santa Fe or
something like that okay all right well
what I would tell you is that I would do
if I woke up in your shoes what are you
driving now what's the car worth you're
driving now
um the car I'm driving now the Santa Fe
and it is probably worth around 15 to 12
or 15 000. okay
all right again you're more than welcome
sir we'll still be friends if you do
whatever you want to do but you called
us what I would do is I would drive the
car you're driving and pay off my house
and I would pick up
um something fun that I make money
really money good money doing
and uh you're only 58 years old you're
just a pup
yes sir I mean you could go make you
could go make 50 Grand
and not even think anything about it and
then use that money to upgrade the car
after your house has paid off
I love that plan
you got you just got this you got all
this potential right in front of you and
so if I'm you I want the car I agree
with you but I'm going to do it smart
and that way have you ever bought
something Rodney and by the time you
finish paying it off or by the time you
owned it a little while you knew you
shouldn't have bought it and you hated
the stupid thing that you thought you
were going to love yes that's what this
is going to be if you do this wrong
because you're already too smart to do
this yeah
done I think
I think for and I think the longer that
you sit around you're going to be
looking for more things to buy
so you gotta go make some money if
you're sitting around all day figuring
out what you spend it on you know you
know what that's gonna be me I have to
do that I have to be careful because if
I'm sitting around I'm planning the next
trip or the next car purchase I'm just
like that I hadn't even thought of that
oh my god I've got the money that's
different but yeah I used to work from
home before I came here and now that
I've come here to Ramsey I come in here
every day you don't spend as much money
I don't spend as much money yeah you
don't you're working man I used to sit
around it's like you're sitting looking
around your house just looking for
things to replace yeah it's what
happened during covet man that's why
Home Depot stock went up man it's so
true yeah so yeah so Rodney let's go
ahead let's keep an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses let's
start chunking down on that house let's
get that house paid off and then let's
save up a beyond that and the best the
fastest way to do that is just make some
more money
you could double your income without a
lot of effort yep yep you're you're only
making about 45 000 a year with your
current retirement income and you could
easily go make another 35 or 40 just
screwing around I mean really it doesn't
you don't have to work that hard but
just go do something all with the idea
that when I get my car and I got the
emergency fund I got the house paid off
I'm gonna quit that and I may sit around
do nothing again except you'll be trying
to spend again but yeah but yeah that
that that's how I would do it if you'll
do this after you have figured out a way
that's fun and reasonably easy to make
some more money and you have paid off
your house and you have your emergency
fund and then you pay cash for the
upgrade on the car if you do it then and
buy a one or a two-year-old One You're
Gonna feel really good about Rodney
treat work like it's a sentence and when
my sentence is over I get to and it's
and it feels like like that you know you
should be able to find work that you
enjoy doing and not and for him it
doesn't have to be eight hours a day you
know all the time it doesn't have to be
a ground yeah it doesn't have to be a
grind it could just be something you
enjoy doing the weird thing is your
highest
income potential across the board now
it's not true of everybody but I mean
the average is people in their 50s wow
between the age 50 and age 60 you make
the most money of any decade of your
working life because all the stupid
stuff you did in your early years is now
called experience
and you got to dial in and you hit the
sweet spot every time you hit the ball
that's cool you know and then 60 you
start to slow down and calm down but
most people make the most of their money
in their 50s so you got a real
opportunity Rodney still got two of
those years left this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade wash all
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Megan is with us in Las Vegas Hi
Megan how are you
hey good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
um yeah so I had a question
um my mom 68 she was the caretaker of
five people
um my dad was one of them and they
divorced years ago but it was a platonic
you know relationship where he lived
with her he has dementia
and
um my mom nine months ago suddenly
passed away and so
um so now we are trying to kind of pick
up the pieces she cared for several
other people and so I've been kind of
overseeing their finances making sure
their four walls are secure and
um she didn't have a will and her
finances were a hot mess so I've cleaned
it up and I've saved a lot of money for
the family with like their social
security
uh income coming in and everything
um and so my dad has a little bit of
savings because
um you know I've been packing piling it
away for him
um so now we're realizing he he probably
needs to move on and out of the house
where it would be a better situation for
him so he's going to move in with my
brother
in Utah and my brother is moving out of
the apartment and he's moving into a
house where you know my dad would have a
space his own bathroom and things so now
I'm thinking well maybe my brother
should take over his money but I'm
hesitant because my brother doesn't have
the best track record with money
he's 47 he doesn't own a house
um he sold his house years ago and he
has a big healthy savings from that but
like he just it doesn't have anything
else to show for so
that's where I need you to come in why
for me I feel like if you've been
handling the finances up until this
point
I don't see a reason for you to change
it
um or do you feel good about your dad
going to live with your brother
do you like that solution
yeah so he wants the best for him and um
we both kind of agree with the majority
of you know what our plans are for him
now when you said that you don't like
the way you're not worried in any way
that he would misuse any of the money
that year that's going towards your dad
are you
I I you know like a couple months a
couple months after my mom died he was
like we need to buy my we need to buy
dad an e-bike because he can't he lost
part of his vision when he had the
stroke which caused dementia we need to
buy him an e-bike so he can get around
and I'm like okay what are you thinking
he's like we need to get him out those
really nice ones that are like three
thousand dollars I'm like we don't have
three thousand dollars to spend on this
you know it's just things like that and
then I'm like oh red flag what are you
gonna do with this money
why don't you just why don't you just
move him in with your brother you're in
agreement on that and then you agree
that you're gonna your dad is gonna pay
your brother X number of dollars rent
per month to cover food lights water and
rent
and you just send him that check and you
manage the rest of it and that's kind of
what I'm thinking yeah that's what's
been happening but I don't he's like
well you know like with inflation uh
well I mean whether inflation what I
mean how much is the rent how much is
the lights and water and how much is the
groceries with inflation and just take
it you know take half of that and that's
your number right
two two grown men living in the house
right
yeah yeah there's no inflation on this
it's just what it is we don't have to
build in an inflate it's not like it you
know we'll reassess it once every six
months but for this six month period of
time here's what we're actually spending
on groceries lights water and rent
and I'm gonna give you half of that and
you're going to cover the other half
right so she says something like life
should take over the money like do you
say no okay and then I just say I'll
send you x amount yeah and cover this
yeah I'm not comfortable with that part
right now but I do want to make sure
that you've got that you're treated
fairly and that you get plenty of money
to take care of that and that he's not a
financial burden to you as a matter of
fact it would be fair to pay more than
his half because your brother's
providing the service of caring for an
Alzheimer's patient
yeah so it'd be fair to assess you know
put another thousand dollars a month on
there or something what's your dad's
income
yeah that's the issue he uh he has
social security income and that's all
he's got and how much is it 23 2300 a
month unless it take to buy half the
rent and half the groceries and half the
gas
well because my brother hasn't moved
into this house yet he hasn't picked a
house yet we're not sure but he my dad's
been contributing a thousand to his
current my mom's household and that's
that doesn't matter that's small town
Utah yeah that doesn't matter where does
your brother live and how much is the
rent well you think the rent's gonna be
on the house
and he lives in Salt Lake what do you
think the rent's gonna be on the house
uh maybe over 2022 maybe okay let's call
1100 your dads then yeah but and then
he's got he's got to buy groceries and
electricity on top of that and give your
brother a little something else so
basically your dad's social security
check is going to go to your brother
and if you have any say whatsoever in
this I know you don't have a ton
the brothers should not buy something
based on your dad's contribution he
should buy what he can afford does that
make sense rent he's renting yeah but
still he can't get something you don't
do what I'm saying I don't want him
dependent on Dad rent something that he
can afford yeah true rent so I want to
make sure that's solid too because if
he's renting something that's like you
know he's so dependent on the money
coming from his dad and I just feel like
that's going to make things awkward as
well yeah I mean if your dad passes away
your brother's Upper Creek he's up a
creek you know because Social Security
stops at death hello so yeah that's this
is the thing you got you just need to
lay it out but this is not going to make
anybody wealthy in this situation but
we're trying to keep your brother whole
meaning that
he's taking on extra expenses for your
dad and he's providing care so with all
of that the majority of your dad's
social security check is going to go to
your brother yeah that's tough man in
order to cover this in order to cover
their actual expenses and a little bit
of Labor I mean that's fair a lot it's
not like you're giving you know he
doesn't need 20 000 a month but he is
gonna need two if eleven hundred dollars
is half the rent and that's probably not
that unrealistic in Salt Lake you know
it's probably not that bad yeah so
that's what we're looking at so you just
got to walk it through like that and I
don't know what your brother taking over
the money would really solve except he
could drain the savings account yeah I
don't like that and I'm just saying you
know I'll go ahead and give you the
social security check we'll sign that
over to you and then you call that
taking care of dad and call that the
rent or something about like that just
like that's it that's about what it's
going to be and then I'll keep the I'll
keep control of the savings and if we
need to do something else for Dad you
and I'll talk about it but um meantime
you keep his half of the expenses on
under his Social Security cost and you
will have a little bit of payment for
helping take care of him and thank you
for that act of love you know that's a
wonderful thing
wow that's tough that's a tough
situation not easy it is you know it
solves it
hundred dollars a month
from age 25 to age 65 invested is one
million one hundred and seventy six
thousand
you know what you could do if you're in
that situation with an extra million
hire Home Health Care anything you want
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thanks for joining us so
the Associated Press is reporting a 16
year old high school senior in New
Orleans received scholarship offers from
149 colleges and universities totaling
10 million dollars
wow 10 million
okay Guinness Book of World Records I
think I read that yeah probably yeah
unbelievable great a GPA of 4.98 it's
gonna go to Cornell he chose Cornell out
of the 149. now let's understand that he
does not have 10 million dollars in
scholarship money coming right he had
that equivalent offered from all of the
different schools added together she
would have had to have attend them all
to get the 10 million that's right
because they're all giving him the day
but still he he got I mean it just blows
out of the water no let me tell you this
did not just randomly happen it's not a
lightning strike right
yeah he had a clear path and clearly
some folks in his Corner that were
looking at you know after him he says
today's an exciting day for me and my
family I look forward to working with
the Cornell College of Engineering over
the course of my undergraduate it says
that he plans to study computer science
that's very very cool
uh okay said in an interview last week
the major reason he cranked out
applications to close to 200 schools was
his desire to have numerous educational
Financial options he ultimately was
accepted to 186 colleges and
universities the school said it believes
the 10 million a scholarship offers from
149 as a record by college just been so
you know he did what we teach and uh
what Ramsey Personnel former Ramsey
personality Christine Alice said yeah
and she had a book confessions of a
scholarship winner who was on the air
here with us for quite a while and got
500 000 not 10 million but she got 500
000 in actual scholarships actual money
in her hand and then went to two schools
getting a degree and then getting a
master's degree and paid cash for all of
that of course
um so what did she do she filled out a
bazillion applications for scholarships
what did he do he filled out a bazillion
applications for scholarships he did not
say I want to go to that school over
there that has the pretty buildings and
is another state where my boyfriend is
going and I know it's nine hundred
thousand dollars to go over there and I
don't have two nickels but that's where
I want to go it's my dream school you
don't want to be a dream killer do you
no these kids put in work they worked
this as though it were their full-time
job and they worked yeah and did you
notice there's not a dream school no 149
possible 186. gave him scholarships yeah
and then he goes okay now I have options
yeah when you have lots of options you
know what you can pick whatever you want
when you when you narrow it down and my
my dreams
you got to create the options the
options don't just you know you don't
get to just willy-nilly choose based on
nothing based off of sticking your
finger in your mouth and throwing it in
the air that's not how it works so
there's a couple of things that we know
and if you haven't seen the documentary
The award-winning uh documentary
borrowed future that we did there's a
couple things we know if you want your
kid to go to college
your kid wants to go to college
100 of the time they can do that debt
free
you should never
have to
take out a student loan but Dave
because you know yeah so let's talk
about how you do it okay number one
thing
if you want to go to college debt free
pick a school you can afford boom
that might mean going to community
college in a lot of states is free yes
for the first two years transfer those
two years of work to your four-year
degree and that you know if you take two
years worth of credits to Auburn or the
University of Tennessee or wherever
Alabama wherever I'm taking good
Southeast schools here at the University
of Michigan whatever right they take the
two years worth of credits and you start
as a junior when you graduate you know
what your diploma says Michigan okay
doesn't say Michigan but went to
Community College but Dave my daughter
wants to go to the state school with all
her friends I know I know she does and
you ain't gain money either
so she gets to go where she can afford
to go so in-state tuition
to the state school is by far the best
bargain by far and you get quality
education and you graduate in a degree
that actually has use in the marketplace
we don't need any more people with a
degree in left-handed puppetry or German
polka history those degrees have no
value you're going to be a barista okay
you're going to be stuck and then you're
going to be whining about the student
loan debt and how the culture is taking
advantage of you study something that is
actually usable where you put tools in
your belt okay so we're going to go to
school we can afford we might do
Community College we're going to get
scholarships we're going to apply for
you need to apply for 200 to 500
scholarships if you get turned down for
all of them but a handful you'll still
get 30 or 40 thousand dollars heck yeah
you will yeah you've got to spread your
net wide yeah and you'll catch some fish
that way and then here's another thing
parents while these uh people are in
college these children that are in
college these adults are in college you
know what else they can do work
wow that came out quick it was almost
like you said it it was so weird that
was weird
make it work Dave it's not child abuse
it's not they actually the students that
in stock they tend to manage their time
better they tend to have higher gpas and
they graduate in four magical years
instead of five wow there's a little
list of classes that if you take these
classes you finish in four that's right
it's just a check box it's just a chance
you have to just go to that class go to
that class and go to that class if you
go to all those classes then they give
you the degree if you pass all of them
and so you and it's scheduled to where
you can do that in four years that's
right I don't know what else you're
doing other than playing beer pong well
my daughter says she can't work because
she's got too big of a class load Dave
you're killing me here
you're killing me here no me look hey
let me just tell you if you the kids
that are athletes on scholarships they
have a full-time job they sure do and
they get their classwork they sure do I
know because I was one they do it and so
I mean we work with athletes on a lot of
a lot of college campuses and they do it
all the time I wouldn't want to do that
I'd rather go out working and making
money personally but
um you know work
choose a school you can afford and moms
and dads it is your job
these are 18 year olds their brains are
not fully formed yes they can't choose a
job to love them so well that you will
not participate with them in doing
something they can't afford to do
no I will not give you my money and I
will not give you my support
if you are going to go to the if you're
going to go on a track that's going to
put you in a student loan debt no I
won't I don't have to see that's called
good parenting I was so mad at my Mom
this is a 30 year old but she made me do
this and now I think she's a genius boom
no right there you go I'd rather you
would rather than be angry with you on
the front end when they're 18. oh I
don't I wonder why didn't you stop me
yeah but then you stop me because there
wasn't any stopping you you were
hell-bent on stupid
you know but you're gonna do it without
my support but if you're gonna do it the
other way I'm gonna I'm gonna help you
I'm gonna do everything I can I'm gonna
put money into the thing if I've got it
I you know you pick a school that's
smart you pick a degree field that's
smart you work and you get scholarships
you can go to college debt free let me
just tell you the average in-state
tuition right now is eleven thousand
dollars that you can do that
well that's a part-time job you can do
that it's not even a good part-time job
that's what I say whatever you look for
you're gonna find if you look for
excuses why you can't go to college debt
why you can't do it you'll find that but
if you look for reasons that you can do
it you will find that as well you will
find ways to get scholarships ways to
work ways to find colleges you can
afford that's the way it works you get
to make a choice it's very very possible
to do so it's um this idea that pop you
know Rachel Cruz used to say and she's
right and she still says
um but I was she's the first person I've
ever heard say we don't have a student
loan crisis we have a parenting crisis
right on
because you got to look at these people
I remember a guy called me from Michigan
he said my son told me he's going to
this school that we can't afford what do
I do and I said well see that started a
few years back because my son doesn't
tell me anything well not when he was a
minor nowadays he does tell me stuff but
yeah but back then when he's a minor I
taught him stuff I know I would have
been like I know you're not talking to
me you told me what
I'll make another one look just like you
yeah okay all right I know you're not
talking about me take you out oh man
yeah brother that's true all right so
debt free college is possible most of it
mathematically is school choice 11 000 a
year or fifty two thousand dollars a
year that's a big difference in private
and across the street is public and
there's no correlation between that and
being successful that's right none this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today paying off debt is smart saving
and investing is smart but there's one
way to win with money the people
Overlook you not only have to play
offense but you also got to play defense
you got to have the right Insurance in
place there are 10 kinds of insurance
that are not rip off that you might need
and we built a free tool called the
coverage checkup to show you which types
you need to add drop or adjust and we'll
tell you about the uh scamos the uh oh
those weird little policies that nobody
needs but we all get them right no no no
we're going to get rid of those and put
that money in your pocket so it's a free
thing it's called the coverage Checkup
go to ramseysolutions.com checkup
ramseysolutions.com checkup don't let an
emergency sneak up on you got the right
kind of coverage in place that's playing
defense not against insurance I'm just
against dumb insurance
so ramseysolutions.com checkup Stacy's
with us hey Stacy how can Jayden I help
hi um my husband and I are both 51 and
um I just recently received a really
large inheritance from my father and
Mike
um one million dollars wow wow cool yeah
I'm sorry for your loss happy for your
game
he uh he followed your steps my husband
and I have followed your steps where on
base
seven and
um we've been debt free for uh for a
long time now and uh so we've recently
been talking about moving and we were
thinking about building a new home and a
new home
um cost would be six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars which to me is
mind-blowing because I've lived
um a pretty uh Dave Ramsey kind of life
where I've been saving and investing and
um budgeting and I'm just wondering what
your thoughts are when if you think I'm
being irrational with not thinking about
building this house
how long ago did your dad pass away
last year
um
do you guys have in addition to the
million inheritance
um we have about
um
1.2 million in retirement funds and 124
000 in savings and then we own our own
house as well and it's worth what
it's worth between
320 and 350 000 we're thinking we could
probably sell that for yeah okay
all right um and so at this point with
the inheritance and with your house and
everything you have over a two and a
half million dollar net worth
so a 650 000 home is perfectly in line
okay that'll make my husband very happy
and by the way it helps me in situations
like this to say it's not really a 650
000 purchase because we're selling a 350
000 house
okay it's a three hundred thousand
dollar purchase because that's all
you're increasing
okay that's great and so yeah the the
Dave Ramsey Way is live like no one else
so that later
you can live and give like no one else
it's not be frugal your whole life and
stack up money to the ceiling
it's enjoy some of it give some of it
and continue to invest some of it and
this is the enjoying part because you've
done a really great job and so did your
dad and I he would be honored by that
both of you you got great DNA and you
did a good job
haven't you no
no yeah thank you I mean you really I
mean you were millionaires before he
left this
yes and he was a millionaire
this is we're talking like rich people
Legacy stuff here
ever have anybody call you rich people
no you're rich people
it's kind of hard for me to think about
it I know it's true I can tell because
you think of yourself as broke what's
your household income
um right now it's two hundred and eleven
thousand but when we started I was a
stay-at-home mom I know when you started
so it is normal for your emotions to not
keep up with your financial growth
when this stuff kicks in and you look up
and you go okay we were we've been
scratching and clawing so long we had to
watch every nickel make it scream
and and pinch them pinch them pinch them
right and then all of a sudden you look
up and it's been a decade and you've got
some serious money and then it's it's
normal for your emotions to not catch up
I mean like when you and Sam got free
you mathematically intellectually
realize they paid off 465 000 he
mathematically realize it's there but
you still it takes your spirit a while
to accept that I'm free absolutely it
does I think about that regularly I have
to remind myself sometimes
so I get what she's saying but Stacy's
Rich yep she is wealth and good and you
know why because she's been diligent
over a long period of time diligence is
excellence in the ordinary on a daily
basis that's right do it all the time do
it all the time do it all the time like
reading the story to my little grandson
I think I can I think I can I think I
can I think I can the little train that
could right I mean this is this is the
stuff and this is how that's exactly who
she is yeah the problem is you get in
that you get in that grind and you don't
look up and realize wait a minute I have
one because she was a millionaire
over a million dollar net worth he
leaves another million so another over a
two million dollar net worth approaching
a three million dollar net worth can you
afford oh and by the way folks if you if
your emotions
um deloney talks about facts are your
friends when you're analyzing things
okay facts are your friends they help
you tell you tell you if your emotions
are lying to you if your emotions are
saying you can't do that you're broke
people
and you're looking at well 650 as a
percentage of 3 million or a percentage
of Two and a Half is a small ratio
ratios are facts okay can you buy that
car
because that car
when you were broke and 25 and starving
to death and coupon clipping that car
was ridiculous now that car is Pocket
Change small piece and you know and you
just you just buy it's just pocket
change it's just fun that's all it is
and its ratios help you tell you if
you're out of line if your emotions are
telling you you can't afford that that
your your frugality is holding you back
because you haven't looked at the ratios
and said it's a small percentage to buy
that car to buy that to upgrade the
house by 300 000 when your net worth is
almost 3 million that's right that's a
small ratio and think about it because
before her house was worth 350 she had
1.2 now she's gained another million and
she's basically going up by 300 more
it's the same it's the same piece of the
pie ah it's exactly the same reason yeah
exactly the same we're not changing the
ratio at all
so when you look at it like that she's
not really upgraded ratio wise yeah
if if he if she had not inherited that
suddenly and you just look down and said
two and a half is 650 reasonable yeah
yeah yeah you would say that's
reasonable but in this case that doubles
it because all she did is she doubled
her almost doubled her net worth a
little you know not quite and a little
bit with the inheritance and really Dad
would be smiling because Dad doesn't see
this as irresponsible that's right if he
did he wouldn't have left her the money
if he thought that she was irresponsible
he wouldn't have left her a million
dollars yeah but he wouldn't see this
act as irresponsible no not at all yeah
it's not it's not so that's a good thing
it's a great question Stacy this reason
we're riffing on a little because a lot
of people deal with this as you move
from the being broke and get out of baby
step two and you finally get the stupid
debts paid off and you can breathe and
you've been living on nothing and you've
been working all the time and you know
you don't do anything then all of a
sudden you get your emergency fund in
place and you go wait a minute now we
can we can actually go out to eat that's
right and then it feels weird look Sam
and I went to the movies the other week
and you know back when we were dating it
was like if we want a date you're
looking at every you know Penny he said
Jade I don't care what this costs
look I got a glass of wine now I will
say we got two drinks it was forty
dollars and I did clutch my pearls I was
like wait a minute wait a minute and
this is movie theater one yeah come on
Dave Come On Dave we can't all have come
on come on come on you know with the guy
the waiter with the come on yeah but we
don't have to not get over it or wine I
mean that's like oh that's nasty let me
live Dave I do want you to live that's
the point I want you to live a long life
all right next time it will be a French
Bordeaux okay you can sneak that in all
right
let's Sam spring for it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the Day psalm 28 7 the
Lord is my strength and shield I trust
him with all my heart he helps me and my
heart is filled with joy I burst out in
songs of Thanksgiving
Martha Washington said the greater part
of our happiness or misery depends upon
our dispositions and not Upon Our
circumstances Martha Washington there
you go right on behind every great man
there's a great woman and a surprise
mother-in-law there you go open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Jade wash all Ramsay
personality is my co-host Ted is with us
in New York hi Ted welcome to the Ramsay
show
Dave
today for you
my question okay my question is about 10
years ago I'm 60 years old about 10
years ago I got talked into an annuity
and didn't realize how bad they were
started listening to you a couple of
years back and uh I'd love to be able to
get out of that annuity and I just need
some help any advice
are you at 10 years you should be past
the surrender charges
under charge
I I'm not sure how much it is but it's
there's 365 000 in there yeah and
um ten years highly unusual for an
annuity to have a surrender charge after
10 years
highly unusual are you sure you need to
check on that
yeah I will I'll check on it um last
time I don't think you did if you
checked on it at seven year it might
have had one
yeah that's probably the last time I
checked on it okay well so here let's
pretend it does let's pretend you have
an unusual one and it does have a
surrender charge that's substantial if
it's small just forget it and pay it and
go I mean 10 or whatever just get your
money out of there and go put up mutual
funds right
um so get it go to Ramsay Solutions and
click on Smart investor to find one of
the people that are in our Network that
we recommend
they're they're got investment Brokers
and those guys can look at your actual
documentation and actually you know and
and read through it with you and tell
you what you're you know and get in
touch with the company on your behalf
and find out what's really going on and
you can move the money that way over to
those guys to manage and some good
mutual funds
um or there's one other possibility if
there's a huge surrender charge and this
would be really for other people that
are listening I don't think you're going
to find that but let's say you were five
years in and there was a 30 charge or
something well you wouldn't want to do
that you but you can roll a fixed
annuity into a variable annuity
oftentimes with the same company and
avoid any surrender charge until you can
get out of the variable annuity now
variable annuity Ted is mutual funds
inside of the annuity and so it'll be
it'll perform a whole lot better and
their variable annuities aren't bad
fixed annuities suck but the variable
news aren't bad but I I would rather you
have it in just low turnover mutual
funds but a variable annuity is not a
bad product uh it's certainly better
than being stuck and you can do that
roll over without the surrender charge
in most cases again a smart investor Pro
can help you do that very cool with the
variable annuity you can choose the
mutual funds inside of it right exactly
and re-choose them you don't have to
just choose them once I mean you can
change the mix you decide I don't like
it you can reset it reset it it doesn't
it doesn't start the clock over and but
you're still kept on the game right or
you're still capped on what the
performance no no no they give you a
minimum floor a lot of times on the
performance they'll tell you that it
will at least make six percent
um and we'll protect your principal and
we'll let you name a beneficiary so they
have the variable annuities have some
benefits to them but the um uh but it
you know you wouldn't use those unless
you've got like extra money laying
around and you're 100 debt free you're
maybe step seven you know you got
millions of dollars and you want to put
some over here to protect the principal
in case of a market downturn or
something like that but um and you can
also use a little bit of estate planning
tool because you can pass outside of
probate by naming the beneficiary
interesting go straight like a life
insurance policy go straight to the
person then there's no tax
oh interesting all right that's a nice
feature that they have but again I
wouldn't do it just for those but that
those are while you're at it you might
as well enjoy those features and again a
smart investor Pro can tell you when the
Ramsay team would suggest that and they
will suggest it at the same exact time
and um because some people are misusing
these variable annuities and putting
people in them that shouldn't be in them
too too early while they still got dead
while they haven't maxed out their
retirement accounts they haven't paid
off their house yet that kind of stuff
you would not use a variable annuity
until you've done all of those things
last Stitch yep yep yep Kim is in
Virginia hi Kim Welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave and Jade thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
yeah I was calling
um because I am laying my decisions for
how to pay off my student loans I have
about 48 000 in student loans and I have
all of that in a high-yield savings
account right now I mean obviously right
now the student loans are in forbearance
I'm not a current interest in the
savings is occurring about four percent
so I'm wondering if it's smart to just
hold on to it until a final decision is
made and then just paid off on the day
that it starts reoccurring interest just
pay them off
pay them off you're going to sleep
better tonight
and here's the thing you
have forgiveness just mark my words it's
not going through it's not and whatever
I'm not like banking on it coming
through but I'm like why not make some
additional money on this savings right
now let's pretend let's pretend for a
second
let's pretend you were debt free
and you didn't have any money in a
high-yield savings
and I came up to you and I said hey Kim
I want you to go borrow thirty thousand
dollars
and the government's got a program
they're not going to charge you interest
for the next few months
and I want you to take that 30 000 I
want you to put in a high yield savings
account
in other words I want you to go into
debt so that you can have a high yield
savings account when I put it that way
it sounds pretty stupid
pretty much yeah yeah that's that's what
it is that's what it is it's just hard
to see that you know it's not hard
active not hard at all money it's not
hard at all you're not gonna get rich
doing this you think that you're gaining
something you're not you're not gonna
you're not even making any money I mean
what's what the crap is four percent of
twenty eight thousand even forty eight
thousand a hundred a month yeah I mean
it's not going to be in your life yeah
it's not changing your life yeah yeah
you can't strut around your bedroom
acting like you're doing something
sophisticated you're just not or the den
or anything else you know I mean come on
it's not it's just it's it's a hundred
freaking dollars yeah you can't buy a
pizza I mean you know no we're and we're
screwing around with this and and you
and you're worried about to the point
you called a national radio show where
you knew we were gonna tell you because
she knows what to do she knows what to
do you knew what we were going to tell
you this is this how worried you were
about it so yeah you clean it up you're
gonna the the piece on the other side of
this and then just use your money to
make money use your money to make money
and this idea that so guys that this you
know uh
in the financial world when you borrow
money and invest it at a rate higher
than the borrowed cost we call that
Arbitrage
and um and they teach it in finance
class what they don't teach you
is that every time you do that
you increase risk that is nowhere you
can get a master's degree in finance and
they will not associate borrowed money
with risk mathematically that's
unbelievable with one exception and that
exception is is that it when you're
taught when a company a publicly trade
company has too much in bond
too big a balance and bonds outstanding
that's debt that you would associate
that with risk and reduce their stock
price because they're carrying too much
debt
but otherwise we're not taught anywhere
in sophisticated Financial World nowhere
even at the Masters of the PHD level to
mathematically associate risk with this
which when you put a risk factor on this
on a tiny little spread like four
percent and you put a risk factor on it
like I don't sleep good tonight yeah it
dissipates the returns
they're just gone yeah you know they
disappear so it vaporizes them so it's
just it's just it's a very incomplete
view of how the world really works
puts us out or the Ramsey Show and the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]